ranger suarez 26 year old venezuela
making his 11th start of the year so
overall he has an era of 1.60
reynolds at 295 average with 24 homers
88 runs batted in
fly ball right field
going back on it is harper he's got
plenty of room sunglasses on makes the
catch
three fly ball outs just seven pitches
for ranger suarez mo crow the starter
for pittsburgh 100 k's 50 walks
matt vealing leads off against will crow
ground ball through the hole at shirt
stop yeah the ball's jumping off his
back yeah that's noticeable and he can
let out fly and bryce harper now with
his 97th walk here comes jt romuto
on the ground
and a good choice great choice
one pitch later crow is out of it a
scoreless first in philly there's
anthony alford who did not start last
night oh for four in the series
92 right on by him yeah tied him up
but that's a sneaky 92 wilmer defoe he
launched a home run last night hits one
over to third and the philly's gonna
return the favor five four three double
play that one looked a little sharper i
gave him a 9.99
that was pretty sweet two outs and
torrey is the batter he's had a big
series he hasn't started until today and
the pitch swung on and blooped to right
defoe chasing after it won't get there
it drops checks up on him now rolls away
so dede can head off to third base so
being there with a belly flop slide kind
of a lob wedge out into shallow right
field depot going after it but couldn't
get it suarez is a 217 career hitter
hanging up there for alfred yeah he was
heading played right shallow toward the
line scoreless frame issued by will
crowe tucker switch hitter from the
right side
swinging a miss
second strikeout one out here in the
third bring up the pitcher will crow
the 01 swinging a bouncer past the mount
slowly hit dd to his left he's got it
crow is barely jogging one two three
inning will go to the bottom of the
third feeling led off the game with a
base hit at the second but was left
there right he winds in the 2-1
swing and a drive center field pretty
deep going back on it reynolds still
going back looking up and that ball is
gone matt feeling with his first major
league home run
just to the right of the 409 sign he
drops it into the banner's eye and matt
bierling has a big league homer
one-nothing phillies standard high-five
from sagura but a full-on hug from bryce
harper as he makes his way to the dugout
he gets to wear the home run hat for the
first time here's harper where the base
is clear 2-1 pitch
swinging a high fly ball deep
center field straight away
reynolds out of room it is gone
number 34 for bryce harper solo shot and
it's two nothing phillies
dead center into the batter's eye and
harper teed off on that one well that
was way up in the air yeah it was that
ends up hitting off the bricks way up
into the ivy and they're two quick outs
that's six ground ball outs for ranger
suarez and it brings brian reynolds to
the plate
and strike three called on the inside
corner he did try to bust him in three
strikeouts through four innings for
ranger suarez the philly's up to nothing
to bring up wilmer defoe he's got
probably the hardest hit ball of the day
but it turned into a double play
defoe bunts and easy play that's as
cliff lee like casual as you'll find
from ranger suarez it's just six pitches
he's in cruise control right now here
comes gene segura he's over for two
looped out towards center and defoe's
not going to be able to get there segora
that's a special yeah segura special
right there good hitters get those you
know bring up jt romuto
broke his backgrounds into shortstop
newman charges tough play and jt beats
it out an infield hit he's got two hits
today
and he keeps the inning alive for brad
miller
oh vacation hole at shortstop segora is
going to cruise on home rbi single for
miller it's a three-nothing phillies
lead how about those three singles for i
don't know how they do it i'm just going
to hit it over there there's nobody
standing there i'll just hit it over
there the bleeder by segura the infield
hit by real muto and a straight up
ground ball to shortstop for a knock the
third run of the day for the fighting
phil's walk mccutcheon for a second time
today the bases are full of phillies and
if howard can get out of it with
gregorius at least kept his club around
that'll do it one pitch and he's out of
there done beautiful howard strands the
bases loaded keeps it a three-run game
major suarez needing 45 pitches to get
through the first five innings
nice play brad miller glove side
sprawling
with his gold schmidt glove he makes the
play three out assisted one out
excellent play ranging to his left
that's only the second hit for the
pirates but then ben gammo will pinch it
back toward the middle on one hop dean
he's got it goes to the second base bag
for one fires to first in time
i gotta tell you ranger suarez can
probably pitch to tomorrow the way this
is going i mean he's getting ground ball
outs and his teammates are picking them
up no runs one hitch another one pitch
out for ranger suarez they'll bring up
the shortstop kevin newman and the 2-2
pitch
back toward the middle and off the glove
picked up by dede running and throwing
in time
1-6-3
seeing some classy defense here today
off the deflection from the glove of
ranger suarez dede gregorius never gave
up on it he makes the play over the
first so here is yoshi sutsugo here it
comes swinging a mess he struck him out
so to go down on strikes and rangers
suarez with his fourth k seven shot out
innings for the phil's left-hander 70
pitches in seven innings for ranger
suarez today here's the wide up in the
payoff pitch
strike three call
fastball inside corner got him looking
all those pitches away a way away and he
comes up paints on the inside corner
here's the 2-2 swing in him see got him
three consecutive strikeouts for ranger
way out in front of that change-up he
turns it over a little bit defeat way
out in front here's the wide of the 2-2
swing and a miss he got it ranger suarez
strikes out the side in the eighth
inning one two three go the buccos eight
scoreless for suarez today when the
phillies have needed him the most
and the leadoff man is on to start the
ninth and we'll see if that props the
phillies to get any sort of activity
going pretty sure he won't need that the
equation is
who's better than the guy i've got on
the mound right
ground ball to first base williams has
got it goes to second for one no and
back to first in time
luke williams comfortably made the throw
to second after d recovered from a split
he was able to fire the first three six
three two outs
twenty eight thousand plus they're on
their feet here at citizens bank park
the 2-2 ground ball to shortstop hit
sharply this should do it dede across
the diamond in time
it's a four hit shutout for ranger
suarez on a day when the phillies needed
it most they win it three to nothing he
was amazing this afternoon and that's a
baseball that should go in a very
special place
because ranger suarez has pitched the
bills to their fifth consecutive victory
you